c'est ce qu'on peut appeler un accord en
bonne et due forme par un simple
communiqué le bras droit du président
américain pour la politique étrangère
anthony blinken a confirmé il tendance
et les derniers échos venus de la maison
blanche les etats-unis et la russie en
coordination sur le dossier du nucléaire
le président biden s'est engagé à
protéger les américains des menaces
nucléaires en rétablissant le leadership
américain en matière de contrôle des
armements et de non prolifération
aujourd'hui les états unis font un
premier pas pour tenir cet engagement
avec la prolongation du traité new start
avec la fédération de russie pour fin
quand un communiqué aux accents
patriotiques les deux pays s'accordent
donc pour renouveler leur confiance
mutuelle sur le sujet jusqu'au 5 février
2000 26 signé en 2010 sous l'ère obama
le traité limites notamment les arsenaux
nucléaires stratégiques et de pays à
1550 ogives soit une réduction de près
de 30% par rapport au précédent plafond
fixé en 2002 à moscou se félicite du
maintien de cette stabilité stratégique
et appellent washington au sens des
responsabilités
la conversation téléphonique entre le
président russe vladimir poutine et le
président américain joe biden le 26
janvier 2021 a été déterminante pour la
poursuite de cette évolution
la russie est prête à faire sa part nous
demandons instamment aux états unis
d'appliquer une approche tout aussi
responsable et de répondre à nos
initiatives de manière constructive
mercredi l'accord russo américains
étaient applaudis du côté de l'otan les
alliés de l'otan estime que le traité
new start contribuer à la stabilité
internationale et les alliés exprime une
nouvelle fois leur ferme soutien à la
poursuite de sa mise en oeuvre et un
dialogue rapide est actif sur les moyens
d'améliorer la stabilité stratégique le
traité new start est critiquée ces
derniers mois par l'administration trup
le 45e président américain souhaitait
que la chine puissance nucléaire
émergentes rejoignent la table des
négociations
mais sans égalité à tous les étages
pékin a décliné l'invitation